this week the bitcoin conference is
taking over miami but that doesn't mean
that we shouldn't look at exactly what's
happening with bitcoin itself first if
we start we can see that bitcoins
trading just over 43 000 it's continued
to hit that 40 to 45 000 range over the
last couple of weeks if we then look at
the bitcoin network itself what we can
see is that the inflation rate still
sits at one point seven seven percent
we're just over an 800 billion dollar
market cap the real exchange volume sits
at just under four billion dollars the
miners have been paid about 40 million
dollars over the last 24 hours to
continue to secure the bitcoin network
on top of that bitcoin is down 37 from
the all-time high but it's up 30
from the local cycle low if we then go
ahead and we take a look at the price it
has traded only 260 days ever above the
current price point that means that for
94
of bitcoin's life bitcoin has been
trading at a lower value than today and
so if you purchase bitcoin and held it
to today you are a happy camper then if
we go when we look at the compound
annual growth rate what we can see is
that bitcoin's compound annual growth
rate over the last 10 years is
148 percent that destroys gold the s p
500 nasdaq or tlt
also the five year sharpe ratio is
superior to any of the other assets then
let's go take a look at dylan leclair
he's got a great tweet here where he
explains that bitcoin is just correlated
with qqq over the last 30 days the two
assets traded with a rolling correlation
of 0.9 that means that many people in
the bitcoin market treating bitcoin as a
risk asset as they have traded those
tech stocks they also are trading
bitcoin the more that those two things
trade together the more that the fed's
policies are going to matter over a long
period of time bitcoin is a
non-correlated asset but in short stints
like this they tend to get highly
correlated then if we go and we take a
look we have the strong hands
accumulating bitcoin at a feverish pace
you can see here using the 30-day
illiquid supply change the far right
it's just going parabolic more and more
people going ahead and buying bitcoin
and then not selling it over a 30-day
period
then let's go take a look at who the
hell actually owns bitcoin first we can
go and we can check out willy woo where
he says it's a false narrative that
bitcoin is hoarded by a few that's
propaganda from the media there's
roughly the same number of bitcoin
whales as billionaires in the world
whale holdings continue to distribute
evenly even on track for 12 percent of
supply by 2030 and retail investors are
gaining fast
then he shows us this great chart which
is the bitcoin supply distribution by
participants and what you can see is
that there is massive growth in retail
ownership and the whales continue to
sell their bitcoin to that retail
audience then we can go and we can take
a look at will clemente we can see that
will also pointing out retail is
currently buying at the second highest
rate in bitcoin's history looking at
retail's holdings most spikes have
coincided with macro tops but on several
occasions they have bought strategically
this spike is the outlier and that's
exactly what you need to be paying
attention to right now the bitcoin
conference has announcement after our
announcement after our announcement the
momentum is real and we can look at
these on-chain metrics so we can see
what their impact is on the bitcoin
price bitcoin continues to hold strong
in the face of a dire financial
situation for billions of people
globally and as there's high inflation
and also undisciplined monetary and
fiscal policy bitcoin has gone up
hundreds of percent over the last two
years and it continues to look strong
based on these fundamentals i'm excited
to see what happens the rest of this
year and we will talk more about bitcoin
next week hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time